so what one final cut yeah will they
become our masters no it will not be our
masters what I'm really worried about is
well who will become our masters are
owners of large tech companies who use
these tools to to control human beings
first unintentionally and then
intentionally so we need to make sure
that we democratized AI it's the same
kind of same kind of thing that we did
with government we make sure that we at
the heads of tech companies if maybe
people in the store will be heads of
tech companies one day we have people
like George Washington who relinquished
power at the finding in this country
forget forget all the other horrible
things he did but the he relinquished
power as opposed to Stalin and all the
other horrible human beings who have
sought instead absolute power which will
be the 21st century
AI will be the tools of power in the
hands of 25 year old nerds it should be
very careful about that future so the
humans will become our masters not the
ai ai will save us so on that no thank
you very much
[Applause]
you